continuing series what's working looks
at innovations that are paying off in
America from education to infrastructure
and more Labor Department figures shows
solar panel and wind turbine technicians
are the two fastest growing careers in
the country Texas is where you'll find
the most of those wind industry jobs the
traditionally conservative state is
leading the way for renewable energy
across the nation Stephen Inskeep
co-host of NPR's Morning Edition and up
first shows how local leaders in Texas
are going green Steve good morning hey
there John glad to be here hi guys a
city we visited in Texas says that on
most days its electricity comes 100
percent from wind power
it's the largest such city in America
and surprisingly one person who made
this possible was president Trump's
energy secretary Rick Perry the guy
who's now been ordered to promote coal
let's begin where the electricity does
at a wind farm in the Texas Panhandle
how many miles of wind turbines are we
walking through here from the furthest
point out on the project to the furthest
point out back there is right about 13
miles Dave Watkins oversees this wind
farm it's on route 66 exactly halfway
between LA and Chicago bikers taking
road trips on this historic highway
rumbled past one new wind farm after
another
I heard someone in town say once that
this this particular area doesn't have a
lot of oil doesn't have a lot of water
but the one thing it does have is wind
which means a job for Wesley house there
this best office in the world he used to
work on oil rigs to me this is more
stable
it's either hit or miss a few years ago
it was Impractical to generate power in
this remote spot then Texas spent seven
billion dollars on power lines
connecting windy north and west Texas
with cities south and east it happened
under energy secretary Rick Perry who
was governor then we can deliver power
to San Antonio Dallas Houston you name
it where the people are yep including
the city that uses almost entirely
renewable power it is 501 miles from
Adrian Texas where the wind turbines are
down to Georgetown Texas where the power
is going we've been driving all
afternoon through the Permian Basin in
the center of Texas and all along the
way we've been passing of oil pump jacks
from an older economy and wind turbines
from a new economy
when we arrived in Georgetown
people told us coal plants kept the
lights on for generations I think it's
kind of cool we have all this history
but also were one of the leading cities
when it comes to innovation in the
country then Republican mayor Dale Ross
concluded the market was changing were
you always a Republican always a
republic you grew up in a Republican
family I did who's your favorite
President President Reagan unlike many
Republicans Ross accepts climate science
he supports clean powers so much he
bought an electric motorcycle but Ross
says he approved wind and solar because
it's affordable this was first and
foremost a business decision and if you
win the business argument then you're
gonna win the environmental argument
have the facts been changing 10 years
ago 20 years ago wind or solar would
have been more expensive right that's
true but now the facts are changing it's
a totally different landscape out there
let me tell you in the state of Texas
since January first for coal plants have
closed this is the economics of the
matter you by wind and solar for say $18
a megawatt you buy coal for 25 you have
that choice which one are you gonna buy
so you're thinking about the art of the
deal the art of the deal I might be able
to teach mr. Trump something when it
comes to renewable energy all he has to
do is invite me and I'll come to the
White House we can have a great
discussion very clean call the president
has hailed a few knock whole jobs the
miners go back to work but has not
erased Cole's disadvantage against
natural gas and renewables my overall
impression is that President Trump has
been able to do less damage than I
feared that he would former Vice
President Al Gore
featured Georgetown's mayor in one of
his climate documentaries market forces
are moving the entire energy marketplace
toward renewable energy I'm hoping
they'll follow the lead of Dale Ross
rather than Donald Trump renewable
energy has continued growing since
Trump's election even in Texas the
conservative home of Trump's energy
secretary so even though Rick Perry is
the energy secretary for President Trump
who's all about cold rah he was in some
way a visionary on wind he was and
without his leadership we wouldn't be
having renewable energy here now he's
shine away from that and I need to be
his PR guy but maybe he doesn't want to
take credit for it cuz his boss is a big
coal guy okay now we did reach out to
Energy Secretary Rick Perry's office and
they say that Perry does take credit for
promoting wind in Texas and that he
still promotes it as energy secretary